[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
look at that hair happy tuesday everyone
and what a glorious tuesday it is
possibly the greatest tuesday in the
history of tuesdays and why is that you
ask well i'll answer i woke up this
morning to find out the new superman
bisexual
finally
as powerful as a locomotive able to leap
from women to men in a single bound
i have not been this excited since i
learned the true identity of the joker
it's scary now it's really it's not
really superman as in the original
superman he's retired living in hoboken
and buying gold from william devane
this is uh john kent superman and lois
lane's son he was super boy for a while
before dad said hey time to become a man
and then immediately got cancelled for
using gender stereotypes so he became
superman
and he hooks up with a young male
journalist don't we all yeah so superman
superman is bi
and i say it's a long time coming jimmy
olsen it was worth the wait because if
there was if there was one thing that
was important to me as a ten-year-old
reading comic books it was who the
characters were sexually attracted to
oh yeah it drove me crazy i needed to
know who batman was sleeping with you
know other than robin
i mean you know calling him the boy
wonder it kind of made me wonder
and he couldn't be sliding down that bat
pole just for fun
i also wanted to know if the archies
were into bondage and i just assumed
aquaman was into water sports thus the
rubber sheets true
i hadn't even reached puberty yet i'm
still waiting in fact but it paid me to
think that our fictional superheroes
were trapped in traditional sex roles
spider-man could swing between buildings
but he couldn't swing both ways
sad
ever since i was a kid reading comic
books i saw that they had more boots
gloves and masks than a leather shop in
the west village it was like brit hume's
closet
and yet
i was as frustrated as a porcupine in a
balloon factory where were the
superheroes who reflected who i was a
sexually confused young boy with acne no
friends and obsession with macrame
it wasn't about finding something
outside my life but something that
reflected my life right because if they
don't reflect my lifestyle then i can't
possibly enjoy it every movie has to
have someone like me in it or i refuse
to watch it
sure some comic characters share traits
with me scrooge mcduck was wealthy but
didn't wear pants
astro boy was short but looked great in
red boots and black shorts
luke cage look great in jeans without a
shirt he's as shredded as a bag of
sargento mozzarella
we shared that in common
no pants awesome abs red boots i just
described kill mead at the last fnc
christmas party
my point is
who really gives a damn
no kid cares or wants to care about who
superman is kissing the guy is faster
than a locomotive and able to leap tall
buildings in a single bound i think that
might peak a kid's curiosity more than
what or who he hooks up with especially
since kids who read comic books usually
don't have sex until their early 30s
[Laughter]
but it raises a question why is this
happening why is this being forced into
a medium where it's not necessary it's
like announcing they have gluten-free
crusts at a pie eating contest
nobody asked nobody cares
but that doesn't matter it's not for the
consumer it's for the companies to cover
their asses there's a desperate need to
virtue signal to those who don't even
read comic books as a way to protect
companies from being criticized for
their past and the criticism is always
the same lack of diversity something you
never hear about in the nba
but companies end up trying
to please people who don't even use your
product you see this with espn that
network sucks because it keeps lecturing
sports fans in order to appeal to a
crowd that couldn't tell the difference
between a jock strap and a sports bra
a mistake i'll never make again
that was awkward yeah it was awkward
at the gym no less everyone everywhere
is so terrified by the woke mob that
they'll turn their art into propaganda
so they hire some miserable gender
studies grad to help them create woke
products that keep them safe from the
online mob suddenly it's no longer about
adventure it's about indoctrination i
wonder what the angry white male has to
say
[Music]
me i have zero interest in the personal
lives of superheroes or comic books for
that matter
i guess i'm old school but i think
adults should act like adults anyway i
gotta get to work
this uh this media stunt also sets a
trap for critics meaning if you say this
is the dumbest thing since salad then
you become the target instead of mocking
this desperate wokism the media will
instead mock those who find the whole
idea absurd so like a chaplain film no
one actually says anything
why well we're nice people but sadly
we're now in a world that insists that
we have to care they demand our opinion
and if we don't give it then we are part
of the problem and just imagine how
superman feels when he's told about his
character update
okay superman as your agents i think you
should know nobody wants a straight
white male superhero anymore okay it's
not enough to save people we have to
appeal to lgbtqia
plus well i can only fit one letter on
the logo okay okay okay okay we keep the
s but we add
a jw
okay now let's talk about your identity
i have a secret identity okay uh well
what about your family life
my dad was a farmer oh god he wasn't
maga was he yeah
uh he died when i was in high school oh
good okay well look you're gonna have to
come out as something okay are you
attracted to men no
women no oh oh you're asexual oh this is
perfect okay everyone's been saying they
want an asexual superhero
no one's been saying that
[Music]
i mean so you're not attracted to anyone
well technically i'm a different species
i'm from the planet krypton oh fantastic
you're an immigrant i'm an alien whoa
oh
easy with the a word
gee okay you know what i think we just
need to get you vaccinated i'm literally
superman
so the divide between your public stance
and how you really feel widens publicly
you can say wow superman you go boy but
privately you know what a bunch of
it is
so go ahead turn superman into political
theater i don't care but every time you
expect me to care i'll crap all over you
even if you didn't pay me first because
in a fair world
in a fair world it is none of our
business
i don't need to know what you enjoy
sexually any more than you need to know
what turns me on and why it requires a
sock full of nine volt batteries
[Applause]
hilarious welcome tonight's guests
he fought for our freedom and look damn
good doing it host of the podcast rob
smith is problematic rob smith
his voice cracks more than the liberty
bell comedian joe mackey
she's like a gerbil playful tiny and
sleeps in wood shavings boxes
contributor cat tim
[Applause]
and when golden corral sees him coming
they surrender my massive sidekick and
the nwa world television champion
for no particular reason i shall go to
you rob smith first you are a gay
superhero yeah
i guess so yes i mean you fought for our
country and you are gay that makes you a
gay hero i threw in the super there
because i'm complimentary um what do you
make of this is this what you call
progress or tmi phrase i just made up
it's it's a little bit of both look as a
practicing homosexual i'm glad that you
came to me first so this is what i think
about this and and i'm of two minds
about this first of all
i hate this sort of retconning of these
iconic characters
having something completely new this is
what i would like as a gay guy i think
it would be cool to have a completely
original gay superhero not to just
retcon something that was already there
before and i say the same thing about
when they have this conversation about
making james bond black i don't want a
black james bond i want some cool
awesome super spy that happens to be
black that is something completely new
so that's kind of like where i fall on
separate but equal how dare you sir
no it makes sense it's like why do you
have to mess with the original just come
up with something new come up with
something new and by the way dc comics
since i'm anointed a gay superhero by
you they should make a comic book out of
me you would be perfect that's what i've
seen your instagram
joe i may be jumping to conclusions here
you were great in the skit by the way
i imagine you were into comic books
what what craig wasn't in that sketch
he was
that's clearly not the guy on the camera
he's just all so handsome yes yes
were you
interested in superman's sexuality when
you were a child greg i don't think
anyone was interested in sexuality at
all after they saw marlon brando in that
skin-tight jerel bodysuit
i was more curious about wanting to be
like superman because he could do a lot
of things that like a dorky nerd
couldn't do like he could beat up a jerk
he could stop a nuclear war by throwing
missiles into the sun that's what i was
interested in i was also interested in
stuff like how could the people of
krypton do nothing while their planet
fell apart but
now with the current administration that
actually seems quite blaso
way to work in a jab on biden i didn't
see that one coming maybe you are
superman maybe yes clearly not oh my god
wow
i will say i felt a tingle there
cat um where are you on this
i think it's fine yeah
that yeah that's just how i feel when
anybody's any kind of sexuality i think
it's fine i think that's
probably going to be the real progress
where when someone's like i'm gay i'm bi
this or that people just say cool and
it's not this huge deal right because i
don't think anybody wants to be defined
by the sex stuff that they do no they
don't
the sex stuff that they do that's or
wanna do or the sex stuff that they do
or that they have done that nobody wants
to be defined by that
or
where they have them
yes i am defined by the things i haven't
done
oh man which isn't a lot let me tell you
that joe
okay the one thing i might be doing that
is wrong is attributing the wrong
audience to this product this is a this
is a comic book that isn't really for
kids right i mean isn't it for just
dorky weirdos you know um i'm sorry joe
a couple of things here you know
to be one i have been defined by my
sexuality before uh on several occasions
by different partners i've been called a
chubby panda
i wear that as a badge of honor
apparently i'm really lazy that's fine i
do the best i can get off my back but
having said that i prefer to be known
for other things
to his point
i
read common books my whole life i still
collect them i still keep them i never
really cared
what a superhero did behind closed doors
but i really feel it cheapens
the message make invest if you're going
to support
the the gay community if you're going to
support gay men and you want to make a
gay superhero have the decency to give
us a great backstory have us see the
struggle have him see him come up and
have him see him survive and then people
wanna will be inspired by him and it
won't be just any it'll be all kids all
guys
he just happens to be gay and he's a
superhero with amazing powers and he
overcame because that's what really gets
us to fall in love with these
superheroes it's not when they're
tearing down buildings it's the struggle
that they go through that we get behind
and they become these amazing things so
and i do i do appreciate the fact that
he's the child of superman and lois so
they kind of got the right idea but
you can do better dc i challenge you you
can do better when it comes to these
comic books because this shouldn't be
the issue and i've been in entertainment
a long time and
one of the biggest things whenever i
have and especially in the wwe a lot of
the guys i work with
are gay and their biggest argument and
their biggest thing is they hate to be
identified by just their sexuality i'm a
great wrestler
who i'm in the bedroom with it doesn't
matter it doesn't cheat who i am if you
want to talk about
if you ask me i'll tell you but every
time i wrestle i don't want to hear that
is a great gay wrestler he is a gay are
there a lot of great wrestlers it's
wrestling everybody's gay sometimes
[Laughter]
i mean
no and look i have to agree with tyrus
like you're absolutely right because
look you know i do the podcast i do the
stuff i do a lot of fox stuff i'm
talking about god everything around the
sun biden's failures cackling kamala all
this other stuff the gay stuff really
doesn't come out until situations like
this so to speak so i'm not completely
defined by that and i don't think to
your point that most gay guys or lgbt
people or whatever want to be defined
clearly completely by that all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else